manufacture rule there's like a law that
is such a reason the cameras can't
record for how long oh because then they
would be classified as video cameras
which there's different legislation
around it's super weird laws politics
camera moment hey everyone what's
happening I am joined here today by my
friend Jarvis Jarvis you want to
introduce yourself a little bit sure
hi I'm Jarvis I work with Micah I'm a
software engineer and I also make
youtube videos so today we're gonna
answer your questions that you've asked
me via Twitter and on YouTube and yeah
so we can just kind of jump into it can
you give us some general tips on how to
prepare for coding interviews thanks my
advice on preparing is educate yourself
on the format of the interview I think
that a ton of companies do it very
similarly and there are a lot of really
good strategies that work for every type
of company like one is thinking out loud
because the goal of the interviewer is
to assess how you your thought process
and like how you approach solving
problems I would almost say yeah like
coding interviews are meant to ship like
reveal thought process more than it is
to like find that final solution yeah
because even if you get the right answer
if you don't show your work so to speak
it's it's really hard to know if this
person would be a person that you'd want
to work with and like to practice the
whole talking out loud thing like what I
do when I'm preparing for interviews is
that I'll take like a question out of
that book and then sit with someone and
go through it so that they can make sure
that if I'm speaking out loud and stuff
like that um and there's actually been a
lot of literature on this there's a
great book for preparing link in the
doobly-doo to use keys he asks how many
languages do we need to know I think
that a lot of people stress out about
knowing a bunch of languages yeah you
don't need to know that many languages
to be a successful software engineer
what is important to know is these basic
concepts that are expressed by the
language Java is an object-oriented
language most things about that language
are object oriented when you take an
object-oriented programming class you
learn about those sorts of paradigms
and then but put those in your back
pocket now any object or any language
you pick up c-sharp or something and you
basically know how it should work and
the syntax is something that anyone
should be able to pick up because the
language is not the important part it's
about solving problems yeah great answer
and then the second part yeah the second
part the is it okay to be scared when
you don't know when to code I unlike
someone who when there's like a big task
in front of me like I have like a big
programming project or something
I see the whole thing and then I get
really intimidated and I kind of like
back away slowly but one trick that I'm
still kind of working on is just to take
it one step at a time and so you kind of
have this huge thing in front of you but
okay let's break that down into what
that actually means into smaller tasks
and then that into even smaller tasks so
then you kind of have like a very
well-defined list of small things to do
which amount to the big thing so then
you don't feel as overwhelmed you're
scared to do the thing and it becomes
kind of like okay there's one foot after
another and next thing you know you're
kind of like I already started then
you're kind of driving and coding and if
you're in like a class or something and
you're assigned a project and you just
don't really know where to start it's
like it's like okay to ask your peers
it's okay to ask your TA like you know
sometimes you need to be shown the ropes
a little bit in order to know like
exactly where to start and that that's
okay I was wondering what do you think
are the main differences between a
software engineer a web developer in a
computer IT person I think this is
important question feel like I get this
question a lot so let's break it down
software engineer that's what we are
yeah that's what we are basically just
means a person who engineer software
which means the planning development and
execution of a software project so
everything from a mobile app like an iOS
app to a web application yeah and I feel
like software engineer is used
interchangeably with software developer
they're really basically synonymous and
then in a web developer is very similar
I think to a software engineer but it is
a bit more specific you might hear the
term web engineer as well and oftentimes
this means someone who is comfortable
working with web technologies usually
this person knows the whole web stack
and is comfortable with that it's like
thinking about it as like a software
engineer or a software developer with a
web specialty so if you say like iOS
engineer it means like you're a software
engineer but with an iOS specialty yeah
so IT is a trickier one ideas has some
overlap in the beginning with computer
science or software but there are a lot
of differences in the actual job IT
people are usually working with a lot of
the devices that are important to making
an organization run if this person
doesn't do their job right the whole
organization shuts down and cannot
function all right next question is from
Miguel acero what tools or side projects
do you recommend making or have you
enjoyed making I would say make
something that interests you make
something that benefits you directly
because I think those are the types of
projects that are gonna motivate you to
actually work on them yeah at the same
time like beside projects can easily
become like a huge project like say you
want to build an app to like track your
calories for instance yeah that can get
really complex really really quickly and
then it can get kind of like too big or
overwhelming a piece of advice that I
have for like side projects is like make
them small make them like accomplishable
within like a couple months or maybe
like either less than a month just
remember that you're doing it for fun so
yeah you when you aren't having fun
anymore it's okay to not do it life's
too short to not have fun there we go
yeah all right our friend Derek Reynolds
asks what's the most difficult
conversation you've had in your
professional career Oh
Derek you're asking the hard questions
so I think that the concept of difficult
conversations is like very real
conversations are hard feelings are
involved you want to just communicate
the best you can while keeping
everyone's feelings intact because you
never want to make anybody feel bad for
me the most difficult conversation I had
was actually with my last boss leaving
my last job it was you know something I
thought about long and hard for a while
and then when it came to it came time to
like call them into a conference room
and like deliver the news it was very
difficult I felt like I had to defend my
decision luckily they were pretty
receptive to it and understanding
and didn't think I was like making a
mistake of my life or anything like that
but yeah like getting over that hill was
like pretty pretty tough so the most
difficult conversation that I've had in
my professional career is probably the
first time that I delivered like
critical feedback to a co-worker one
thing that I didn't really realize
coming in to a software engineering job
out of college was how important
managing your relationship would be with
other people you're working close to 40
hours with these people and so it's a
given that you're gonna have little
rifts and Tiff's and you're not gonna
see eye to eye on everything a lot of
the times it's like miscommunication it
was like misunderstanding though yeah my
last job there was someone who I didn't
really get along well with and I
couldn't really understand what their
attentions were for what they were
saying yeah I talked to my manager and
he gave me a couple tips I'm like how to
approach the situation and yeah we just
kind of talked it out and we realized it
was a misunderstanding and I felt so
much better after talking about it but
it was so hard to like do that I was
like I have to talk about my feelings to
a co-worker totally yeah and yeah I
wanted to touch on something that you
said which is that you spend a lot of
time with these other people and your
relationships with them are very
important software engineering is not
about going into a cave for 40 hours a
week and writing code as what one single
person it's all about teamwork and
planning in relationship building that's
most of the job to be honest like I if
you ask me like how much of my day I
spend writing code it's like some days
it could be 0% and other days maybe it's
50% but still like there's a lot of
facets to the job software engineering
is fun alright thank you so much to
everyone for all of your questions this
was really fun this is so fun yeah we
should do my Q&A yeah job is working
everyone find you you can find me at
youtube.com slash Jeff Jarvis Johnson
I'm sure there's like gonna be a link or
something somewhere and you can also
find me on twitter at jarvis where you
can read really bad jokes this has been
pretty serious stuff so we're gonna go
over to my channel into a video where we
do YouTube challenges
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up if you liked it and also subscribe to
my YouTube channel for more videos
[Laughter]
[Music]